here's what would happen if you sailed
the Galaxy on solar winds solar winds
carry charged particles ejected by the
sun these particles fly across the solar
system at blisteringly fast speeds of
1.6 million kilometers per hour
these are the sales that could take you
across the Galaxy Electric sales they're
kind of like an umbrella without the
fabric only these ribs would be made of
electrically charged aluminum wires with
a 1 000 kilogram spacecraft like yours
well you'd need about 100 wires to catch
solar wind particles reaching speeds of
up to 150 kilometers per second you'd
navigate by simply changing the voltage
levels on different wires of your
electric sails but don't venture too far
away from the Sun once you cross into
Interstellar space the sun's solar winds
weaken significantly hopefully you could
navigate close to another star and power
up again because